the Joe Rogan experience you know what
do you think of that how do you say his
name let ray lamontagne is that how you
say it yeah he's like a songwriter yeah
do you know that song Jolin I do that
song yeah he's got a really cool voice
but ham my buddy Dan did a record with
him and I've never met him but now he's
a really cool dude my dude his voice I
think he's kind of like he was sort of
if I'm not mistaken I really will
totally came into it later like I did he
had like jobs and [ __ ] before and then
just started doing it and that makes
sense found success later on I think
that makes sense with a lot of people no
I just think people like Justin Bieber
like he's kind of way harder road it's a
way harder road to try to figure out you
a man like all things considered he's
probably handling it okay he's handling
it he's a nominally you think about he
was what [ __ ] 8 24 years only four
holy [ __ ]
he just told us already having just
turned 24 and he's rolling around on a
g7 that's his day-to-day you know
because whatever the [ __ ] he wants all
the time yeah you know you don't pay
attention to things I'm not like uh I'm
not glued into pop culture but somehow
like you just can't not know what Justin
Bieber's up to once a month just walking
around in the world any more of it I
would say that kid for most people to be
handed that type of existence and all of
that scrutiny and all the [ __ ] that
comes along with that like that does
things to people you know it definitely
does especially if your personalities
not even formed yet yeah I can't imagine
into this business at 35 yeah and not 21
cuz I was talking to my friend John this
weekend about this and I was saying that
it's almost like if he made an epoxy
right you know if you have epoxy has put
a couple ingredients in like there's one
thing he makes it with another thing
then it hardens but if you add some [ __ ]
in that that's not supposed to be there
and it's fully developed right you're
not gonna take that [ __ ] out like if you
added oil you threw some oil in the
epoxy like I know you [ __ ] that whole
thing up that's kind of what you're
doing to a person
when you raise a person famous if you
take some reality star from the time
they're five and then they're gonna
sitcom in a movie and then you've gone
through your whole oh no I said reality
star but you've gone through your whole
life if you're that person if you're
Justin Bieber you've gone through your
whole life under that under the eye and
it's gotten bigger and bigger and bigger
and more and more people paying
attention like you never had a moment
like you did well you're working for the
railroad tracks right or like you know I
did going on the road for years or some
of the jobs that I had before I was ever
a comedian they don't have any of those
they don't don't have the wondering if
you could pay your bill feeling they
don't know that feeling they don't have
the I see I still feel like that mm-hmm
you know that's what's [ __ ] up my wife
I'm just like I'm still like I just I'll
never not feel like that you know yeah
from never never really had money or
anything like that or any aspirations to
own a house or those kind of things so
it's just I'm you know especially with
kids now like I just don't it's there's
no flamboyance yeah but now he he lives
a different life for people like Rihanna
these they're like literally citizens of
the world and any day of the week they
could be in some five-star hotel and God
knows where you know yeah god knows
where yeah it's a crazy way to live
very bizarre jet-setting flapping I
couldn't do it man because there's no
way I don't know I don't ever want to
wake up and have that kind of career
because it takes so many people around
you there on a daily basis just to
maintain and keep seeing something a
machine that large rolling logistically
speaking that you become enslaved to the
job you know to me because you have all
these there's like there's always this
name like when you have superstar X you
know you put this head right here and
then everything below that just to make
that thing go around you know then it
just turns into this it's like a
corporation really like with 20 semi
trucks and all this [ __ ] you know and
you got to go out and make that happen
because now all these people depend on
for their livelihoods and careers and so
then that's gonna affect the artistic
decisions you make because you have to
stay relevant culturally speaking and if
you want to do something different next
time well now this massive fan base
isn't really gonna [ __ ] and deal with
that very well
like when Beastie Boys put out Paul's
Boutique exactly people on what the [ __ ]
there what the [ __ ] but now it's a it's
you know a the class most greatest
records ever made but people back then
didn't know what to handle they didn't
know what to do with that they didn't
they didn't have the the Beastie Boys
classified in the artists box right they
had them in the pop music box so this is
silly you gotta fight for your right to
party we get it you know you guys are
partiers cool and then also you know
Paul's Boutique is like whoa what is
this mm-hmm I mean like David Bowie went
from Ziggy Stardust to doing a solo
album and like nine months with Luther
Vandross and yeah those are huge classic
amazing records now but like you realize
those guys were playing theaters when
all that [ __ ] happened whoa and he's
just like I'm done with this I'm gonna
go do this now you literally can't see
any more because I [ __ ] killed it on
stage yeah that's over you know do you
think Rod Stewart gets enough credit I
don't I don't either I think especially
man faces and even though these are
little records those are some amazing
albums his voice is incredible
you know what having him what the hits
got too much [ __ ] do you think about
brain once he hit that everybody's like
check please he's like no that's all I
got to do because remember go back to
Maggie Mae you know wake up like that
song was that was there was something in
that song right there was a guy trying
to figure his life out hanging out with
some chick yeah Rod Stewart's a bad fit
oh man what is that song as they called
Maggie Mae yeah Elton John
all those guys like that's yeah he was a
big different level but they started
wearing like leopard tight pants [ __ ]
because he could I mean look at that
[ __ ] it ain't like it's not working he
actually was I think he almost played
professional soccer for Celtic or
somebody wow you
like a really great soccer player when
he was a kid but he was too small so he
had just and he's another one right that
like basically that you're never gonna
see one of those again no I don't think
so you're never gonna see a lot of
things again just because it there's
just no nobody that's actually that
might know that's not necessarily true
you might see more things now because
that's true too right no I was ahead of
myself like I you know for all the times
I shouldn't be here right you sure that
it wasn't an industry creation right so
Nellie anything really is possible
[Applause]